[Musica]
papaveri
girasoli
avete sentito bene
papavero i girasoli non papaveri e
papere allora vi starete chiedendo ma
perché mauro oggi ci parla di due fiori
intanto perché sono molto legato alla
mia terra le colline marchigiane e molti
dei miei ricordi hanno come sfondo i
campi dei girasoli che coltivava mio
nonno e io da bambina andavo lì
raccogliere quei fiori rossi e vivaci
e quindi è stato molto facile per me
sceglierli come metafora delle dinamiche
complesse di alcuni ambienti lavorativi
e mi riferisco in particolar modo ai
gruppi di decisione negli ambiti delle
stem stemma è un acronimo che sta per
scienza tecnologia ingegneria e
matematica
in questi ambiti
l'affermazione di sé l'espressione delle
proprie potenzialità la carriera la
leadership le ambizioni sono spesso
soggetti a forze che vogliono noi donne
in qualche modo essere orientate ad
avere un codice di comportamento che ci
vuole silenziose diafane spesso noi
siamo presenti in quei gruppi di
decisione ma con i nostri contorni diamo
poco colore a quel tavolo
ecco il senso alla mia domanda girasoli
o papà per il girasole un fiore
antichissimo risale alla mitologia greca
una ninfa fu trasformata in un fiore è
obbligato a girare la sua corolla verso
il sole noi utilizziamo il girasole come
simbolo del sacrificio delle idee del
pensiero per vivere di luce riflessa
il papavero il papavero fiori indomito è
un fiore resiliente anche lui è presente
in tantissimi miti e leggende mamme mi
ha colpito particolarmente l'uso che ne
fa tarpino il superbo nel racconto della
fondazione di roma in cui mi ma il
taglio delle teste degli alti papaveri
per spiegare al figlio come conquistare
l'indomita città di gavi
alcuni ambienti lavorativi sono dei veri
e propri campi di girasole in cui la
voce delle donne e in generale direi la
voce di chi la pensa diversamente
rimane a volte inascoltata
alcune donne addirittura pensano di non
poter assumere un ruolo di leadership e
quindi decidono di avere un
atteggiamento sommesso silente
altri invece adottano un comportamento
maschile ma perdono quei tratti di
femminilità che poi sono il vero portato
che loro possono dare a quel tavolo di
decisione
e allora io ho tante volte mi sono
chiesta come può una donna emergere qual
è la decisione giusta da prendere è
meglio essere accondiscendenti e seguire
passo passo le indicazioni che a volte
ci vengono date da un dio sole nella
speranza di raggiungere i nostri
risultati
oppure per seguire le nostre ambizioni
tracciare la strada che noi riteniamo
essere più opportuna per noi stesse
ovviamente assumendo sul rischio il
rischio è quello del fallimento è
possibile secondo voi uscire dallo
schema del girasole
beh i dati sicuramente non ci confortano
e mostrano un problema davvero
strutturale
pensate che solo il 9 per cento delle
studentesse universitarie
frequenta corsi di laurea stem che sono
quelli che garantiscono maggiori sbocchi
lavorativi
opportunità di carriera salari medi più
alti e se saliamo ai vertici della
gerarchia vediamo che questa percentuale
si assottiglia ancor di più
solo il 3 per cento delle donne e
amministratore di impresa e allora cosa
posso fare io per cambiare queste
percentuali
vi posso raccontare la mia storia io ho
scelto di essere un papavero
spontanea
ribelle a volte messa ai margini ma
sicuramente appassionata del mio lavoro
e io ho scelto di essere un papavero non
un giorno fa un anno fa ma ho scelto di
essere papavero come il risultato delle
tante le scelte che ho fatto
nell'arco della mia vita e delle
reazioni che ho avuto di fronte a quelle
dinamiche di cui vi parlavo
da bambino volevo fare la stilista mi
piaceva creare cose belle e quindi
decisi di iscrivermi a una delle più
prestigiose scuole di moda in italia il
giorno che misi piede in quella scuola
io vi giuro fece dietrofront e me ne
ritorna nelle marche perché avevo
sentito che era un mondo un po effimero
non risuonava con me
e quindi
fece una scelta che probabilmente cambiò
per sempre la mia vita e fu quella di
iscrivermi all ingegneria edile
architettura
avevo compreso in quel momento che la
bellezza va oltre le forme in cui si
incarna e altrettanto avevo capito che
avevo anche un'altra passione che era la
matematica la logica e allora ho detto
bellezza matematica non sono poi due
dimensioni
così distanti l'una rispetto all'altra
quello era il percorso giusto per me
un secondo momento di svolta celebri
molti anni dopo
camminavo lungo i corridoi
dell'università e vivi la stanza del mio
relatore di tesi vuota
entrai dentro e provare una sensazione
fortissima quel professore per me era
stato illuminante perché per primo ma
aveva spiegato la relazione tra
tecnologia e bellezza e quando mi misi
seduta sulla sua poltrona capì
immediatamente qual era il mestiere che
volevo fare io volevo fare il professore
universitario e volevo farlo perché
volevo aiutare i miei studenti a
comprendere le loro passioni e magari
incanalarle nell'ingegneria
l'opportunità di intraprendere questa
carriera mi fu offerta con un dottorato
di ricerca ma in ingegneria meccanica
ma io in maniera istintiva colsi
immediatamente la sfida andiamo a capire
se c'è spazio per la bellezza
nell'ingegneria mente manica il tema che
affronta i per primo fu quello delle
tecnologie di realtà virtuale in realtà
aumentata reale e virtuale due estremi
di un continuum spazio temporale in cui
possiamo andare a scoprire delle
tecnologie capaci di estendere le
capacità umane per poter vivere dei
mondi immaginari finalmente stavo
avviando mi per la strada della carriera
accademica ma fin dai primi momenti
iniziai a confrontarmi con quelle
dinamiche ed alcune di queste dinamiche
sfruttano l'epiteto l'epiteto genera un
meccanismo in tutti noi
particolare perché si riferisce alla
sfera professionale
pur essendo etichettato in un ambiente
di tipo lavorativo
in questo modo ha una funzione molto
importante perché serve proprio per
sminuire le competenze serve per
silenziare una voce che è differente
vi racconterò di tre epiteti che per me
sono stati di ispirazione il primo
epiteto è inadeguata io come ingegnere
edile architetto sono un po inadeguata
perché non sono né un ingegnere di un
architetto
lavoro nell'ambito l'ingegneria
meccanica ma io non sono un ingegnere
meccanico e nonostante ho studiato
tantissimo per mettermi alla pari con i
miei colleghi
tutt'oggi quando i miei studenti mi
chiedono prof mi spieghi la differenza
tra un giunto sferiche una forcella io
ok poi rispondo
il motivo è perché questo epiteto
instilla in noi un in sicurezza
ti fa sentire fragile
e allora ho cercato di capire come
reagire e la reazione sta nella parola
stessa nell'etimologia stessa
dell'epiteto
inadeguato significa essere non uguale
significa essere diverso
la ricerca scientifica si nutre di
diversità è ricchezza la diversità
grazie alle competenze trasversali che
uno può maturare a una visione ampia e
attraverso questa visione ampia e
possibile collegare dei puntini e
attraverso i collegamenti trovare quegli
elementi di innovazione
che poi sono il vero obiettivo della
ricerca scientifica
vi faccio un esempio per farvi capire un
po questo concetto questo sono uno dei
primi risultati della mia attività di
ricerca sviluppare una metodologia
capace di estrapolare in maniera
automatica
le linee di stile da dei prodotti
industriali per poterle mantenere
inalterate durante l'intero ciclo di
ingegnerizzazione industrializzazione di
quel prodotto perché quelle linee di
stile sono molto importanti perché
garantiscono la qualità estetica spesso
responsabile del successo di quel
prodotto sul mercato
ecco io ho applicato le mie competenze
trasversali per rispondere a un problema
che è prettamente meccanico che
all'adeguamento funzionale
il secondo epiteto è ambiziosa la prima
volta che mi fu detto che ero ambiziosa
fu da parte di un professore di
educazione tecnica era una ragazzina
disse ai miei genitori che io non avevo
né la disciplina nell'intelletto per
poter affrontare il liceo scientifico
io mi sono diplomata con il massimo dei
voti al liceo scientifico quante volte
vi è capitato di sentir dire quell'uomo
è ambizioso e quante volte avete pensato
è un brillante è un figo e quante volte
invece mi è capitato di sentire una
donna quella donna league è ambiziosa e
avrete pensato
vuole troppo è una che avida di successo
e il dualismo nell'interpretazione della
parola ambizioso cielo risolve anche qui
l'etimologia della parola stessa
ambizioso significa andare intorno
avvicinarsi avvicinarsi a cosa ho un
sogno ha un obiettivo e se questo
avvicinamento avviene attraverso la
determinazione il lavoro lo studio
l'ambizione è il ponte delle aspirazioni
e anche qui mi riporto un attimo la mia
storia personale
a un certo momento
avevo la necessità di misurare me stessa
e di misurare anche il portato delle mie
ricerche scientifiche di misurarmi non
solo come professore universitario ma
anche come imprenditrice insieme a un
gruppo di ricerca
sviluppiamo una tecnologia capace di
misurare le emozioni umane dalle
espressioni facciali per poterle
utilizzare per adattare gli spazi
all'essere umano
abbiamo fondato una start up oggi questa
startup dopo cinque anni di duro lavoro
e tra le prime c5 start up in europa ad
alta tecnologia guidate da una donna
e parlando di emozioni vi parlo
dell'ultimo epiteto emotiva quante volte
avete sentito parlare quella donna è
emotiva anzi diciamo la parola giusta
senza pudore e uterina
tu sei troppo irrazionale per e quindi
non riesce a gestire un team sei troppo
emotiva per capire le complesse
dinamiche strategie di questo gruppo di
lavoro
quanto si sbagliano essere emotiva è una
grandissima forza
essere motivi vuol dire andare oltre
irrazionale per cogliere quello spessore
tridimensionale dell'essere umano e fare
quindi scelte più consapevoli più
consapevoli dell'altro più consapevoli
delle situazioni che stiamo vivendo
l'emotività è una forza perché è quella
forza che ci dà la spinta per cambiare
le cose nei gruppi decisione non va mai
considerato un ostacolo tutt'altro
è un'opportunità di includere le
diversità nelle scelte che vengono fatte
io ho abbracciato la mia emotività la
mia inadeguatezza la mia spontaneità la
mia schiettezza io ho abbracciato i miei
presunti difetti per farne dei punti di
forza io ho abbracciato i petali rossi
del papavero
scegliendo di non voltarmi verso una
guida che non riconosco come tale
è chi pensa ancora che negli ambiti stem
non ci sia posto per la bellezza
l'emotività la diversità la creatività
alle mie spalle vedete le immagini della
livrea della formula sae che ha vinto il
primo premio per il progetto nel 2019 il
nostro studente la politecnica hanno
lavorato per creare delle linee di stile
capaci di comunicare valori come potenza
dinamicità forza
piuttosto che le tecnologie che
realizziamo per tracciare gli operatori
negli ambienti di lavoro per rendere
quelle quegli ambienti più sicuri ma
anche più confortevoli pensate che
l'ingegneria meccanica perché più a che
fare solo con l'industria anche no
lavoriamo molto nel creare tecnologie in
grado di migliorare l'interazione tra
l'uomo e l'arte per creare dei percorsi
museali che siano più interattivi più
coinvolgenti più inclusivi
e ovvio è necessario per ottenere dei
risultati che portino a un cambiamento
del paradigma delle dinamiche sociali e
professionali
avere competenza disciplina si passione
determinazione
ma soprattutto libertà di pensiero le
donne possono cambiare la prospettiva di
fare impresa di fare innovazione di fare
ricerca
e a quel punto possono portare un
cambiamento del modello del girasole
dove la voce del sistema e l'equilibrio
combinato di tante voci che trovano un
accordo trovano un'armonia non
riflettono il solo colore del dio sole
bisogna avere coraggio coraggio di
assumersi la responsabilità di fare
scelte autonome riappropriarci della
libertà di autodeterminazione di
pensiero solo in questo modo donna dopo
donna ma anche un uomo dopo uomo
potremmo riempire il campo di girasoli
del rosso indomito dei papaveri
e chi ancora oggi mi dice maura tu sei
troppo emotiva e maura hai detto una
stupidaggine
il respiro poi mi giro e guardo o la
guardo e gli dico hai perfettamente
ragione
d'altronde io sono bionda
grazie a tutti